good morning we know the US Forest
Service is having a briefing this hour
right now for the latest on the fire at
last check it grew to about 5,000 acres
let's give you a live look at the haze
over there hovering right over Mount
Charleston that is the source of the
smoky air you're waking up to this
morning around the valley and with no
containment overnight and strong winds
which we actually feel right now the
fire area is expected to be much larger
today and crews are trying to get
airplanes up well as soon as it's safe
enough so as soon as it's safe enough so
they cannot survey the fire and again it
grew up to around 5,000 acres it started
just before 3 o'clock in the afternoon
yesterday with massive plumes of smoke
around the valley the fire grew quickly
as wind gusts topped around 50 miles an
hour yesterday the wind combined with
the rugged terrain made the flames even
more difficult for firefighters to fight
we're getting gusts up to 50 miles an
hour so the fire could potentially move
50 miles an hour which is very unsafe
for our firefighters so we're taking a
lot of precautions right now about how
close we're getting
the wind kept aircraft grounded
yesterday they hope to get airplanes
back up to us so they can try to a drop
fire retardant this morning and
helicopters to take firefighters a
little closer to the front lines James
Walker says he was hiking when he was
nearly overcome by the fire he suffered
smoke inhalation as the flames roared
nearby I don't want to burn up because
it was intense it was huge within 10
minutes it was a gigantic fire Walker
also said the wind was blowing so hard
it was picking up small pebbles and
shuffling them around on the ground and
back out here live campsites were
evacuated including the people inside
this RV here they were just waiting here
a long time Canyon Road waiting to find
out what's next our live team coverage
continues with Bianca Holman she's live
with an update the latest on evacuations
for people in the area Bianca
hey Hector well there were folks at the
Spring Mountain News cam that they were
evacuated and there was also voluntarily
evacuation for those living in the Lee
Canyon area of course they could come
here to Bilbray Elementary School where
there are volunteers from the Red Cross
here to help them providing food shelter
and water and while it's voluntary right
now that could change at any moment
other precautions were taken to protect
everyone NV Energy shut off power to
Mount Charleston customers and those
outages will extend later on today the
Red Cross has set up shop here at
Bilbray Elementary School to help those
in need and of course there's all the
essentials here for them food water and
shelter we're here for the people I mean
that's what our jobs are at the American
Red Cross this is fire season and we
tell people to be Red Cross ready which
is to be disaster ready which means put
together an emergency kit so that there
is in case you have to leave and
evacuate you have prescription items on
trying to copies of your records that
you need like driver's license and
social security cards and things like
that change of clothes and then you have
a plan
reminders we all need just in case
you're forced out of your home during
this time and of course the Red Cross
will continue to be here throughout this
morning and later on today and we'll
keep everyone updated on if there are
any changes here at the evacuation
center reporting live from sky Canyon
Bianca Holman 8 news now